madame cheneviève Darius sec ministre
délégué chargé de personnes handicapées
auprès du ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2023 j'indique
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo qui sera retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat est
disponible en vidéo à la demande je
rappelle à nos collègues inscrits pour
l'élection d'un juge suppléant à la Cour
de Justice de la République se tient à
partir de 14h30 jusqu'à 15h en salle des
conférences ne soyez donc pas surprises
madame la ministre de voir les
commissaires qui n'auraient pas donné de
pouvoir quitter brièvement la salle pour
participer à ce scrutage je vous laisse
tout de suite la parole Madame le
Ministre
bien Madame la Présidente
madame la rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs alors je vous remercie de
votre invitation à venir m'exprimer
devant vous non seulement sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale mais aussi plus largement sur
les orientations qui seront les miennes
et celles du gouvernement en matière de
handicap
le handicap est une politique
prioritaire du gouvernement et la
première ministre l'affirmé avec force
dès son discours de politique générale
du 6 juillet 2022 elle l'a redit lors du
comité interministériel du handicap qui
s'est tenu jeudi dernier en présence du
gouvernement des associations
représentatives du secteur et des
représentations des élus locaux avec ce
CIH Elisabeth borne a fixé un cap une
méthode et des priorités à notre action
en inscrivant le handicap dans la
feuille de route de chacun des ministres
nous nous assurons que le handicap soit
toujours inclus dans leur action notre
conviction est simple les personnes en
situation de handicap doivent être
prises en compte systématiquement dès le
moment de la conception de toutes les
politiques publiques
en désignant dans chaque préfecture un
sous-préfet référent handicap nous nous
assurons que ces politiques soient mises
en oeuvre sur l'ensemble du territoire
en coopération avec tous les acteurs
locaux concernés et au plus proche bien
sûr des besoins de chacun c'est une
nécessité parce que notre politique de
handicap n'a de sens que dans les effets
directs quel produit sur la vie des gens
dans leur quotidien bien sûr
le caractère prioritaire de cette
politique se traduit dans ce PLFSS par
une augmentation sans précédent de
l'objectif national de dépenses pour le
volet personne en situation de handicap
cette augmentation est de 5,2 % soit 730
millions d'euros supplémentaires nous
poursuivons ainsi les engagements pris
lors de la dernière conférence nationale
du handicap de février 2020 alors même
que nous préparons activement la
prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap qui se tiendra l'année
prochaine j'y reviendrai
beaucoup a été fait depuis cinq ans et
nous pouvons constater les résultats de
l'action menée ces dernières années dans
chaque ministère mais beaucoup reste à
faire
nous en sommes bien conscients et c'est
ce qui motive bien sûr notre action un
enjeu essentiel pour l'accomplissement
de nos ambitions et qui ne concerne pas
uniquement le handicap et bien
l'ensemble des politiques de l'autonomie
c'est celui de l'attractivité des
métiers du secteur social et
médico-social nous ne pouvons être à la
hauteur de nos ambitions sans le travail
admirable que mène au quotidien ces
hommes et ces femmes sur le terrain
c'est pourquoi 300 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront consacrés dans ce
PLFSS au revalorisation de salaires
conformément aux engagements pris par le
premier ministre Jean Castex lors de la
conférence des métiers de février 2022
cette revalorisation est une composante
importante de notre détermination à
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers par
ailleurs le secteur social et
médico-social fait face comme l'ensemble
du pays a une inflation importante
c'est pourquoi après de 150 millions
d'euros supplémentaires seront alloués
aux établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux pour personnes en
situation de handicap afin de tenir
compte de l'effet prix ceci or ma
salarial j'en profite pour vous rappeler
que comme l'a annoncé Jean-Christophe
combe le bouclier tarifaire bénéficiera
également aux établissements pour
adultes en situation de handicap
assimilable à des lieux d'habitation
et les négociations sont en cours de
finalisation concernant les
établissements pour enfants
avec le PLFSS 2023 nous poursuivons et
amplifions la mise en oeuvre de grands
de grands objectifs et de politiques
prioritaires d'abord 70 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront alloués au
développement de l'école inclusive et à
la scolarisation des enfants et
adolescents en situation de handicap
cela permet de financer la création de
place notamment pour la scolarisation
des élèves polyhandicapés et le
déploiement des unités d'enseignement
autisme à l'école maternelle et
élémentaire nous allons également
accroître les coopérations
opérationnelles entre l'école et les
établissements médico-sociaux pour
favoriser la scolarisation en milieu
ordinaire des enfants en situation de
handicap
ensuite 80 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront fléchés en
direction des publics prioritaires je
pense notamment aux adultes en situation
de polyhandicap et aux personnes
handicapées vieillissantes pour
lesquelles nous souhaitons diversifier
les solutions d'accompagnement ces
crédits viendront également financer la
politique du handicap à d'outre-mer qui
accuse des retards importants et à mon
sens inacceptable
enfin une partie de ces financements
vise à prévenir les départs forcés vers
la Belgique tout en permettant le retour
en France de ceux qui le souhaitent
dernier grand bloc des actions financées
par le PLFSS ce sont 80 millions d'euros
supplémentaires dédiés à la poursuite
des mesures concernant l'autisme et les
troubles du neurodéveloppement hors
scolarisation
ainsi nous étions la politique de
détection
précoce qui est l'une des réussites
majeures de la stratégie nationale qui a
permis après de 30000 enfants depuis
trois ans d'être détectés à temps et
donc d'être mieux accompagné et
correctement accompagné c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle nous entendons
renforcer l'accompagnement qui suit le
diagnostic et nous souhaitons également
accélérer le déploiement des unités
résidentielles pour les adultes autistes
voilà donc un plfs résolument ambitieux
pour le secteur du handicap qui
s'inscrit dans le cycle long de la
concertation qui préside depuis
longtemps à la construction de toutes
les politiques du handicap un PLFSS qui
entend appuyé la dynamique des progrès
accomplis depuis la dernière conférence
nationale du handicap par une hausse des
moyens d'ampleur inédites et un bel FSS
qui prépare le terrain pour faire de la
prochaine CNH un vrai tremplin pour la
suite de notre action
j'ajoute au passage que le caractère
transversal des politiques en faveur du
handicap fait que leur financement est
assuré par de nombreux budgets
différents
par ailleurs c'est un PLFSS que nous
pourrions qualifier de transition nous
sommes en effet à quelques mois de la
prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap je vous le disais que nous
préparons activement elle sera
l'occasion de proposer un changement de
paradigme à la hauteur des attentes des
personnes en situation de handicap sous
l'égide de la première ministre 4 grands
axes ont été fixés l'acte 2 de l'école
et de l'université inclusive la
mobilisation pour le plein emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap la
simplification des parcours des
personnes et de l'offre médico-sociale
et l'accessibilité universelle
en parallèle nous prévoyons de prolonger
les efforts sans précédent menés sur
l'autisme et les troubles du
neurodéveloppement en construisant une
nouvelle stratégie nationale et des
concertations sont d'ores et déjà lancé
en ce sens alors mesdames les sénatrices
et messieurs les sénateurs je veux pour
terminer vous livrer deux points
fondamentaux à mes yeux qui seront la
boussole de l'action que j'entends mener
la question de la simplification
est un vrai sujet
dans le handicap et la complexité est
ressentie par les handicapés leur
famille comme quelque chose de très
pénalisant
et la question de l'effectivité des
mesures dans la vie de nos concitoyens
c'est toujours les derniers maîtres et
les derniers kilomètres et mettre qui
sont importants pour la mise en oeuvre
des politiques notre politique est
toujours dit complexe à tous les niveaux
nous souhaitons donc simplifier les
démarches et les procédures et gagner en
efficacité au profit de nos concitoyens
enfin un dernier mot de méthode toutes
nos politiques nous les mènerons encore
certains étroites avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés je pense bien
évidemment au Conseil national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
mais également aux élus locaux et en
particulier les départements et bien
entendu nous souhaitons y associer la
représentation nationale car je sais que
vous êtes nombreux à vous investir sur
ces sujets
j'ajoute que cette logique de
co-construction qui est déjà la norme
depuis bien longtemps dans les
politiques du handicap que j'ai
aujourd'hui l'honneur de porter c'est
précisément ce que veulent introduire le
président de la République et la
première ministre dans l'ensemble de nos
politiques publiques je tiens donc à
souligner en définitive le rôle
d'avant-garde que je vous les acteurs du
handicap en la matière je vous remercie
et je suis prête bien sûr à répondre à
toutes vos questions
merci merci madame la ministre et je
vais danser déjà passer la parole à
Philip mouillé qui est rapporteur au
PLFSS de la 5ème branche branche
autonomie merci Madame présente merci
Madame ministre pour cette présentation
et les différentes remarques que vous
évoquez je ne peux que souscrire un des
derniers points que vous avez évoqué sur
les enjeux de la simplification ce sont
des mesures qui ne coûtent pas forcément
de l'argent mais qui sont souvent
nécessaires en matière de réorganisation
autour de tout ça mais là pour l'instant
nous sommes dans le pfss donc on va
parler éventuellement d'argent dans un
dans ces systèmes de de compréhension
qui est un petit peu difficile parce que
en même temps que nous exinions le PVC
s'il y a eu donc le comité ministériel
qui a fait son d'annonce et nous
annonçant que dans les prochains mois
nous allons aborder le le CNH donc pour
pouvoir avoir quelques grandes priorités
donc il faut arriver à lire leur travers
tout cela en tous les cas on entend les
attentions on entend les orientations
qui sont données qui correspondent aux
besoins mais en même temps un moment
nous additionnons les associations du
monde du handicap qui elle ou
globalement sont plutôt critiques voire
même très critique sur les moyens
alloués dans ce bel effet s alors nous
sommes donc c'est une de mes premières
questions c'est quoi quoi répondre à ces
différents qui considèrent que cette
mise en œuvre à minima à minima des
engagements pris au dernier comité donc
ouais on est déjà dans une dans une dans
une culture à la période voilà donc
j'aurais voulu avoir votre regard autour
de de ces retours des associations et
éventuellement à travers le 6 octobre
dernier vous avez évoqué la mise en
place des sous-préfets dans les
territoires est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
mesures aujourd'hui annoncées lors de ce
comité interministériel très
concrètement pour l'année 2023 lors de
l'audition de de du ministre Combes
concernant le pdfss il nous indiquait
que c'était finalement concernant le
volet du handicap une fin de six
structurel sur des grandes politiques
qu'il fallait laisser le temps de la
constatation sur le handicap pour
pouvoir préparer la future CNH vous avez
évoqué les quatre grands thèmes de cette
de ce de ce comité
la question c'est au-delà des thèmes
c'est l'engagement des moyens c'est
toujours le même sujet parce que je
crois que globalement les thématiques
sont partagées mais quels sont les
moyens qu'on pourrait envisager puisque
nous serons entre deux pelles et FSS et
à travers tout ça notamment je voudrais
faire un zoom sur l'enjeu des aesh parce
que c'est certainement une des
nombreuses difficultés cet aspect là est
un point crucial vous avez mis en place
un système d'organisation transversale
sur l'ensemble des ministères comment
aujourd'hui répondent aux attentes
fortes nous sommes au lendemain de la
rentrée scolaire et on voit que les
retours sont nombreux en matière de
dysfonctionnement également vous avez
évoqué le volet stratégie autisme nous
sommes en fin de cycle le cycle de la
stratégie se termine en 2022 est-ce
qu'il faut attendre le sénage de 2023
comment comment on organise
l'orientation autour de ces enjeux pour
l'autisme
quatrième point peut-être plus global
lorsqu'on regarde l'annexe B du pfss on
nous voyons que pour la branche
autonomie on nous retrouverions une
situation excédentaire à compter de 2024
notamment 09 milliards sont annoncés un
excédent qui diminuerait notamment au
regard des engagements de création de
poste dans les EHPAD et du financement
du temps dédié aux liens social auprès
des personnes âgées autrement dit des
moyens financiers principalement fléchés
autour des personnes âgées ma question à
partir de 2024 vu les annexes proposés
qu'est-ce qui reste pour le monde du
handicap puisqu'on est pratiquement à un
niveau proche de zéro dans les annexes
qui sont présentés
deux derniers points vous avez évoqué
assez rapidement dans les mesures qu'on
peut sentir les moyens consacrés au fond
de l'intervention pour éviter les
départs en Belgique
ma question c'est est-ce que les fonds
N-1 ont été utilisés je ne pense pas ou
très peu et surtout comment concrètement
ça peut se traduire puisque dans les
territoires je fais beaucoup de tours de
département lorsque il y a des besoins
aujourd'hui on était en Maine-et-Loire
là déjà la semaine dernière et bien
finalement les les fonds semblent
inaccessibles même s'il existe
concrètement dans la maquette budgétaire
et pour terminer c'est un élément
complémentaire mon profitons de votre
présence nous avons voté enfin la
décongelisation nous étions présents
dans dans les lois dans les rencontres
pardon qui est ont évoqué sur la mise en
place de la méthode un décret attendu en
mi-décembre est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus sur ce la sortie du décret
puisqu'il conditionne toute la mise en
place de la mécanique du mécanisme pour
la décongélisation
merci je vous répondre à toutes ces
questions avant de passer au collègues
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
donc
il a raison je vais essayer de ne pas en
oublier si c'était le cas je vous
remercie de me rappeler celle que
j'aurais oublié
bon les critiques des associations
à propos de la mise en oeuvre à minima
des engagements pris précédemment bon
un bon texte ne passe pas nécessairement
d'abord par des mesures législatives
nouvelles mais pour moi ce n'est pas un
texte à minima c'est la plus forte
augmentation de crédit en direction des
personnes en situation de handicap
5,2% alors que l'on dame est à
3,4%, je crois donc je veux dire que la
la branche enfin
pas utiliser le terme branche parce que
c'est une signification mais le thème
handicap est bien pris en compte et de
façon de façon importante et je l'ai dit
il n'y a pas que les que ces budgets là
qui sont concernés le budget par exemple
de l'éducation nationale sur les cols
inclusives
ces 3 milliards c'était 3 milliards et
demi cette année 2022 il y a 200
millions de plus il y aura également
j'imagine
pratiquement la même somme de plus
puisque l'ambition est de recruter
encore 4000 aesh supplémentaires donc si
vous voulez la monter en charge se fait
progressivement dans tous les ministères
concernés et je crois que c'est aussi
c'est aussi une il faut que nous
mettions en oeuvre nos ambitions et
notamment dans l'inclusion ce sont des
ambitions sur le long terme donc pas
forcément des choses des choses
nouvelles et bien sûr les politiques de
handicap elles se construisent avec
l'ensemble des personnes concernées nous
arrivons en fin de cycle avec une
nouvelle conférence nationale du
handicap que nous préparons
à partir de la méthode donnée par la
première ministre en comité
interministériel du handicap de la
semaine dernière et nous aurons là une
feuille de route pour les 5 ans à venir
donc voilà
et nous mettons en œuvre aujourd'hui
les politiques qui ont été aussi décidé
notamment par exemple dans la stratégie
autisme où nous continuons de déployer
de façon très active les unités
spécialisées en école maternelle en
école élémentaire nous voyons le nombre
des classes sudistes qui augmentent
voilà donc nous avons cette montée en
puissance elle se fait elle se fait
progressivement
et les nouvelles ambitions alors ça me
fait passer à votre deuxième question
nouvelle CNH quel moyen et bien je crois
que
nous devons construire déjà avec
les associations la feuille de route et
c'est à partir de cette feuille de route
que nous déterminerons les moyens nous
avons par exemple des sujets qui sont
importants et qui vont nous mobiliser
beaucoup autour de l'accessibilité
puisque nous avons une date butoir de
2024 qui arrive pour tout le monde dans
laquelle nous serons immanquablement une
nouvelle fois en retard mais pour
laquelle nous pouvons quand même donner
un
une vraie impulsion là aussi ce sont pas
des budgets qui apparaissent dans le
PLFSS qui qui concerne le handicap et ce
sont pourtant des sujets qui sont
essentiels pour le monde du handicap et
pour l'inclusion donc nous avons
nous avons véritablement ce travail et
les moyens seront mis en perspective
bien sûr des ambitions de cette CNH que
nous déterminerons aussi que nous
co-construirons avec les associations
les annonces qui ont oui je l'avais
oublié celle-là les annonces
en dehors des sous-préfet alors des
sous-préfils en existe déjà mais ils ne
sont pas tous identifiés dans tous les
départements et certains ont pu changer
donc nous allons rappeler au préfet de
nommer systématiquement des sous-préfet
ou handicap et la première ministre a
annoncé justement pour travailler sur
l'accessibilité la nomination elle va
nommer un délégué interministériel à
l'accessibilité pour
impulser une un nouveau souffle ou le
souffle de la dernière ligne droite sur
ces sujets d'accessibilité avec la
mobilisation sur les adaptes bien sûr
et des annonces de Christophe Béchu le
ministre
qui est en responsabilité sur ces sujets
dès 2023 donc ça c'est une première
chose ensuite vous m'avez posé des
questions sur les vous avez sage bon les
aesh
leur nombre augmentent régulièrement
malgré les difficultés de recrutement il
y a deux sujets dans les aesh le premier
sujet qui est le sujet du statut de ces
personnes qui est un sujet important ce
sont des emplois alors ce sont des
emplois de l'éducation nationale je le
rappelle et c'est donc l'éducation
nationale qui travaille sur sur ces
sujets
le président de la République et la
première ministre se sont engagés à
faire en sorte que nous puissions
des précariser ces situations et que
nous puissions proposer à ces personnes
des 35 heures donc un travail est fait
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
avec les collectifs les collectivités
territoriales pour travailler sur ces
sujets puisqu'il y a bien sûr les sujets
aussi de l'inclusion au temple
périscolaire qui qui est un sujet
fondamental donc le travail est en cours
et nous allons de poursuivre de façon
active dans cette année et il y a le
deuxième sujet des aesh
c'est leur nombre leur nombre qui a
augmenté de 42% par rapport à 2017 donc
elles le sont en nombre important il y a
aujourd'hui 130 000 AEH si on le ramène
au nombre de professeurs c'est unaesh
produit professeur
alors professeur tout tout englobé
là aussi moi je souhaite que nous ayons
collectivement une réflexion parce que
je suis frappée par le fait que rentrée
scolaire enfant handicapée égal à ESH
mais chaque enfant en situation de
handicap n'a pas besoin forcément d'un
avsh et ça ça m'est confirmé par
beaucoup d'associations c'est pas moi
qui
certains ont besoin d'outils
d'autres ont besoin d'une pédagogie
particulière adaptée donc les outils et
bien sont des outils que nous devons
pouvoir mettre à disposition les
pédagogies particulières c'est bien sûr
de la formation pour les enseignants
dans ces dans cette pédagogie d'autres
ont véritablement besoin d'une aide
humaine permanente donc n'ont besoin que
d'une aide humaine ponctuelle dans
certains moments de la journée donc moi
je souhaite vraiment je pense en accord
avec le enfin avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale que nous allions
vers une évaluation une mise en regard
des besoins et des moyens et que nous
nous puissions continuer d'avancer dans
ce dans ce domaine là avec un sujet moi
que je trouve majeur quand même c'est
une meilleure
enfin inclusion le mot est pour les
personnes en situation de handicap mais
il faut que le médic social rentre plus
dans les écoles et dans les collèges et
dans les lycées pour être voilà une
véritable force d'appui pour les
personnes les enfants en situation de
handicap mais également pour toute la
communauté éducative et c'est sur ces
sujets que nous allons bien sûr
continuer de travailler avec avec force
et dans la prochaine donc Conférence
nationale du handicap
nous allons travailler sur l'acte 2 de
l'école inclusive et je pense que voilà
nous devons repenser évaluer et repenser
cet accompagnement et voir comment nous
pouvons
davantage
inclure le médico-social à l'intérieur
de l'école
il y a une grande stratégie autisme 500
millions d'euros quand même cette
stratégie c'est enfin quand même c'est
nécessaire c'est déployer d'abord à mon
avis une grande réussite c'est que nous
sommes pas restés que sur l'autisme mais
sur l'autisme et tous les troubles du
neuro-développement c'est à dire tous
les 10 enfin toutes ces les hyperactifs
enfin tout tout ces
typologies différentes de handicap
et que nous avons pu proposer ce
dépistage précoce avec ses plateformes
des
[Musique]
le plus jeune âge de 0 à 6 ans en fait
qui est un vrai et une vraie dynamique
parce que plus les le repérages est fait
précautions plus on peut entourer
l'enfant mettre autour de lui
les bonnes personnes en soutien et pour
améliorer faire en sorte d'améliorer
son son trouble et faire en sorte
surtout qu'il puisse rentrer dans
l'école dans de meilleures conditions
donc
je pense que ça est tout à fait vertueux
et cette c'était une avancée très
importante
nous devons
poursuivre et donc il est prévu de de
renouveler une stratégie autisme et
trouble du neuro-développement et nous
avons bien sûr demandé à la à la
déléguer interministériel à l'autisme à
la DIA de commencer à travailler pour
construire cette stratégie avec une
attention particulière que nous devons
avoir sur les autistes adultes
et bien sûr que nous devons
continuer de porter sur
l'inclusion de ces de ces jeunes aussi
dans le monde du travail voilà je crois
que nous avons des enjeux qui sont des
enjeux
des enjeux à venir importants et tout
cela sera construit avec bien sûr les
associations comme toujours
ensuite vous m'avez posé une question
sur
la vite de tourner les feuilles sur la
l'objectif global de dépenses sur la
branche autonomie l'objectif global de
dépenses sur le champ des personnes
âgées n'a aucune influence sur le taux
d'évolution des crédits du champ de
personnes handicapées
ce sont deux sous objectifs autonomes
et l'autre même s'ils sont tous les deux
intégrés dans la sous le chapeau branche
autonomie sur le champ du handicap la
trajectoire pluriannuelle intégrée à
l'annexe B du PLFSS prévoit une
évolution de tendancelle des moyens j'ai
été et inflation à un taux supérieur à
celui connu les années précédentes et un
quantum de mesures nouvelles d'à peu
près 200 millions d'euros par an
ces taux seront bien sûr revus
annuellement pour tenir compte des
événements conjoncturels ou des choix
politiques que nous serons amenés à
faire et qui suivront après la CNH mais
voilà les je crois que
ces choses sont bien séparées il y a
deux de
distinction entre les deux branches
entre les deux catégories personnes
âgées personnes handicapées et les
crédits supplémentaires fléchés vers la
branche bénéficieront également à
revaloriser les concours de la CNSA au
département et donc la PCH
qui est un sujet un sujet important
les départs en Belgique
alors les départs en Belgique
je crois que nous avons enrayé cette
dynamique qui était très négative pour
notre pays et pour les familles
nous l'avons nous l'avons d'abord il y a
un moratoire qui a été mis en œuvre
ensuite
oui 8500 personnes en situation de
handicap quand même adultes et enfants
sont pris en charge par le secteur
médico-social vallon plus de 7000
adultes et c'était un chiffre qui
progressait chaque année donc voilà le
il y a eu un moratoire pour les enfants
depuis 2015 et
les priorités qui ont été annoncées en
2020 par la Conférence nationale du
handicap par le Président de la
République et l'arrêt des départs
contraints en Belgique c'était vraiment
une priorité qui était annoncée
cette priorité et bien elle a vu quand
même
la mise en place donc moratoire j'en ai
parlé cette priorité
elle a été mise en oeuvre puisque au
total 2500 solutions nouvelles sont en
cours de déploiement certaines sont
déployées d'autres alors 2020
aujourd'hui nous sommes en 2022 je veux
dire il faut du temps pour que les
projets se mettent en oeuvre mais nous
avons véritablement
eu cette action je peux même vous donner
un Île de France depuis 1600 nouvelles
solutions vont être déployées 630 dans
les routes de France 270 dans le Grand
Est
ce plan de prévention des départs non
souhaités en Belgique est un plan de 90
millions d'euros
donc il est mis en oeuvre il se déploie
actuellement et il se il termine son
déploiement actuellement voilà
et nous allons poursuivre et ce qui est
important pour nous il y a même des
établissements belges qui ferment
actuellement dans ce qui est important
pour nous c'est de pouvoir demander
aussi aux personnes parce que c'est de
l'autodétermination aussi de pouvoir
demander aux personnes leur souhait
et nous essayons de faire en sorte
qu'elle souhaite véritable simplement
revenir en France parce que voilà ça
nous paraît
ça nous paraît bien plus enfin ça me
paraît important puisque nos dépenses
sociales soient sur le sol français
et enfin vous m'avez parlé d'âge alors
oui là ça a été voté
enfin la
l'individualisation de la hache a été
votée au mois de juillet
je peux vous assurer que
et une réunion au ministère avec des
parlementaires vous en faisiez partie
monsieur monsieur le sénateur
je l'ai voulu pour que nous puissions
tout le monde puisse avoir le même
niveau d'information et comprendre quels
étaient les raisons qui nous avaient
poussées à demander le 1er octobre 2023
c'est à dire qu'il fallait écrire un
décret qui est complexe en rédaction
les acteurs sont enfin des directions et
les associations sont en cours
d'écriture actuellement pour un rendu à
la fin du mois d'octobre afin que nous
puissions le présenter au Conseil
consultatif et également au Parlement
puisque nous referons une réunion pour
présenter cela sachant que pour moi
l'objectif parce que franchement pour
tout vous dire c'est très technique
moi l'objectif politique c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de perdant
c'est à dire dans la loi comme elle
était votée c'était 45000 perdants donc
c'était inadmissible donc qu'il y ait
des gagnants c'est une chose mais il ne
fallait pas qu'il y ait de perdant donc
c'est pour ça que le décret est un peu
complexe à écrire sur le plan technique
mais les choses avancent l'objectif est
de publier ce décret au mois de décembre
et dans le même temps la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiale
travaille sur son système d'information
système d'information qui est une vraie
nouveauté est totalement différente des
systèmes d'information classique de la
Caisse d'allocations familiales qui à
tous ces systèmes basés sur la
conjugalisation toutes les prestations
elles sont conjuguées donc il faut
qu'ils mettent en place un nouveau
système innovant qui
permet de décongivialiser cet âge mais
qui permet aussi de maintenir les
prestations conjuguées des personnes en
situation de handicap qui ont aussi des
prestations conjuguées c'est pour ça que
ce temps de quelques mois a été
nécessaire comme ça avait été expliqué
pendant cette donc ça avance et je le
redis s'il est possible de le mettre en
application plutôt nous le mettrons
plutôt dès que les choses seront prêtes
mais ce qui me semble souhaitable c'est
que donc d'un côté pour le décret il y a
pas de perdant et de l'autre côté pour
la mise en oeuvre purement
opérationnel pour les familles c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de couac si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi parce qu'il est
toujours désagréable d'avoir voilà donc
je sais qu'on nous attend là dessus et
tout le monde a la pression
merci Madame la Ministre alors nous
avons cinq collègues qui souhaitent vous
poser des questions on va prendre toutes
les questions
Nadia sur le groupe ensuite Jocelyne
guidez
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre notre collègue vous a interrogé
sur les aesh et vous avez répondu que
tout enfant en situation de handicap n'a
pas forcément besoin d'une aesh et c'est
vrai que les solutions ne sont pas
universelles mais je pense que les
collègues inclusive n'est pas non plus
une solution universelle et je pense aux
enfants sourds pour qui l'école
inclusive peut être parfois même au
contraire une difficulté alors je
voulais m'assurer que dans ce budget qui
est prévu il y avait bien suffisamment
de moyens pour que tous les enfants
sourds puissent être pris en charge de
façon adaptée à leur situation non merci
c'est Jocelyne guidage
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous étions ensemble en visite
à Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois et la grande
difficulté rencontrée par les parents
c'est qu'il y a peu de place pour ses
enfants qui finissent un cursus maternel
pour aller en primaire déception des
parents et du personnel c'est pas de
solution ces enfants sont en perte
éducatif alors qu'ils avaient évolué
pendant ces trois ans dans quelle
solution pouvoir apporter après ces ce
cursus maternel et puis je voudrais
revenir moi sur les transports juste
vous donner un exemple une famille
camille a son enfant dans un accueil
perpétuel
il doit faire 86 km année 86 km retour
et belote pour le pour ramener l'enfant
chez comment dire à l'accueil ça fait
plus de 300 km par week-end sauf qu'ils
ont droit qu'à 200 euros
pour les transports ce qui est
impossible puisque de toute façon rien
ça coûterait 200 euros donc je savais
qu'il y avait un travail qui a été fait
par un Cluzel là-dessus mais je ne sais
pas quels sont les retours est-ce qu'il
y a une possibilité d'avoir des
conventions entre département
parce qu'on peut pas laisser ces
familles s'épuiser rien que dans le
transport quand on donne pas les moyens
qu'il faut pour ça voilà et puis merci
beaucoup moi je suis très heureuse
d'apprendre que vous allez prendre en
compte les troubles du Neuro
développement ces états sujet qui
m'intéresse énormément
et vous avez bien dit tous les troubles
merci beaucoup
oui merci madame la ministre pour vos
propos liminaires et la réponse aux
questions qui ont été posées par notre
rapporteur moi je voulais remettre une
petite couche sur la question de la
revalorisation des salaires concernant
des personnels qui travaillent dans des
établissements d'accueil de personnes en
situation de handicap notamment des
emplois administratifs ou techniques qui
restent encore exclus du Ségur et
bon il y a un effort particulier qui a
été fait mais il était nécessaire et il
est nécessaire que l'ensemble des
personnels soient traités de la même
manière ce que ce sont en général de
petites équipes et dans ces petites
équipes vous avez
parfois des un manque de reconnaissance
et et un manque
une différence de fait entre les
différents personnages qui est tout à
fait néfaste à l'accompagnement et à la
prise en charge des personnes comme je
voulais vous alerter à nouveau sur cette
question là parce que c'est une question
récurrente sans parler de la délégation
des crédits qui parfois lorsque le les
revalorisations des années des salaires
sont acquises les associations ont du
mal à assurer en fait les leurs
obligations parce que les délégations de
crédit ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous donc via les ARS
ma deuxième question porte sur l'autisme
je pense qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
travail à faire sur le dépistage précoce
même si les choses ont beaucoup évolué
et je voulais aussi attirer votre
attention sur le fait que c'est vrai
qu'on est et on est tous favorables à
cette société
inclusive qu'on demande de tous nos vœux
mais ça n'exclut pas la prise en charge
dans des établissements spécialisés et
et l'un ne va pas en autre et les deux
sont enfin répondent à des besoins
souvent différents et on ne faut pas
enfin je crois qu'il faut pas négliger
et mettre de côté ses prises en charge
adaptées dans les établissements
au
profit effectivement de la société
inclusive qu'on essaie de mettre en
place et qui est effectivement un
objectif quand c'est possible et ça me
mène à une autre question il y a des
crédits qui avaient été prévus sur la
mise en place de lieu de répit pour des
familles et des enfants qui parfois sont
accompagnés à leur domicile et je crains
que ça ait quelques difficultés à la
mise en oeuvre lorsqu'il y a des projets
enfin j'ai quelques expériences dans mon
département et c'est pas tout à fait
simple et à mettre en place et ma
dernière question concerne
l'emploi accompagné et l'accompagnement
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans l'emploi c'est peut-être pas tout à
fait votre champ mais quand même je
pense que c'est important d'appuyer et
de voir comment la réforme de France
travaille va influer sur l'organisation
et la prise en charge des personnes en
situation de handicap parce que là aussi
on a des inquiétudes qui nous remontent
sur
voilà le
la prise en charge des personnes
handicapées dans l'entreprise et surtout
leur accompagnement par des sociétés des
associations comme par exemple Cap
emploi ou Pôle Emploi parfois merci
Michel meunier ensuite Corinne Imbert
Michel merci madame la Présidente il ne
reste plus vraiment de nouvelles
questions à vous poser puisque mes
collègues l'ont largement abordé les
différentes aspects vous entendez bien
qu'il y a quand même des points de
donc qui justement en tout cas les
choses les pointures à traiter en termes
de handicap et je me disais à vous
entendre quand vous parlez de PLFSS
ambitieux pour la branche autonomie j'ai
des doutes je me dis au mieux on est
dans des confortations de ce qui
existait auparavant et des poursuites et
vous nous mettez en perspective l'acte
de
l'école inclusive dans le prochain CNH
avec des questions sur l'emploi etc donc
on se dit mais au fond ce pelfss il va
servir à quoi si ce n'est voilà
peut-être encore à
conforter l'existant donc je trouve que
le compte n'y est pas bien d'autant que
ce qui a été pointé à la fois sur les
aesh sur la difficulté de recrutement
dans le secteur tout confondu montre
bien que l'urgence des associations que
le l'on entend elle est pas vraiment
prise en compte j'en veux aussi pour
preuve la semaine dernière on avait un
débat dans l'hémicycle avec votre
collègue madame la ministre Firma le
Baudot qui nous a dit en gros il faut
changer le regard sur le monde du
handicap et des métiers du handicap donc
on est d'accord mais comment on fait et
par quoi on commence donc c'est peu ma
question générique que j'aimerais voilà
aborder avec vous Madame la miss
Corinne Imbert et Katia pour ce polir
ensuite Madame le Ministre pour répondre
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre merci pour vos propos
liminaires et pour les questions que
vous avez les réponses que vous avez
déjà apportées aux questions du
rapporteur ma question va être très
courte on a déjà beaucoup parlé
d'inclusion pour autant nous avons aussi
encore besoin d'établissements et
notamment de maison d'accueil
spécialisées de foyer d'accueil
médicalisés et je voulais simplement
savoir s'il y avait des crédits qui
étaient fléchés pour la création de
place en masse et en femme parce que ce
sont quand même les établissements pour
lequel nous constatons les listes
d'attente et plus longue dans nos
départements je vous remercie
pour terminer Katia merci madame la
présidente
madame la ministre donc j'ai bien
entendu que vous allez travailler à la
revalorisation des salaires et regarder
aux évolutions de carrière c'est ce que
vous avez dit en préambule que vous
répondez peut-être et certainement une
demande sur des associations des
personnes en situation de handicap sur
la simplification administrative qui est
quand même une demande
récurrente depuis de nombreuses années
des associations
parce que c'est le parcours du
combattant excusez moi du mot mais je
sais que vous étiez avant vos anciens
combattants c'est le parcours du
combattant pour non mais c'est le
parcours du combattant pour à chaque
fois de voir et bien remplir à nouveau
le dossier retrouver les certificats
médicaux etc etc et donc je pense qu'il
est temps de passer à ça mon collègue
philippouiller a abordé un problème qui
moi aussi
m'interpelle beaucoup c'est sur le
nombre de jeunes et d'adultes qui donc
je suis des Hauts de France
vont en Belgique
on l'avait d'ailleurs évoqué à plusieurs
reprises moi je connais des gamins
aujourd'hui qui prennent un taxi par
gamma par jour qui font 2 heures de
transport le matin et 2 heures de
transport le soir pour aller dans un
établissement en Belgique des enfants
autistes
et qui font deux heures le matin donc
pour se rendre en Belgique deux heures
le soir avec un taxi alors ce n'est pas
la faute de la famille au contraire et
bien bien heureusement mais combien ça
coûte combien ça coûte à la société de
payer un taxi et encore une fois je ne
vais pas du tout en cause ni la famille
ni le gosse parce que c'est normal mais
combien ça coûte à la société de devoir
payer un taxi le matin et le soir pour
que le gamin puisse traverser le
département du Pas-de-Calais et à
l'école et aller à l'école en Belgique
je pense que si nous avions un peu de je
veux pas dire de jugeote parce qu'on en
a tous mais en tous les cas si on
réfléchissait les choses un peu
différemment je pense qu'on pourrait
aller à l'accueil et à la
création de structures dans le
Pas-de-Calais et dans les autres
départements évidemment pour pouvoir
garder nos enfants chez nous parce que
d'abord pour les familles ce serait
quand même bien mieux de ne pas se lever
à 5h du matin pour que le gamin puisse
partir à 6h30 le matin en taxi et
revenir le soir et puis moi j'ai un j'ai
un doute parce que j'ai été interpellé
par plusieurs associations dans mon
département je vous ai interpellé
d'ailleurs madame la ministre et je sais
que vous allez me répondre
mais en tous les cas j'ai été
interpellée parce que beaucoup de
parents
d'enfants autistes qui ne trouvent pas
de solutions qui n'ont aucune solution
enfant ou adulte on montait des projets
pour pouvoir s'organiser avec
ergothérapeute avec donc éducateur avec
AVS pour un montage de projet pour des
accueils de 6,7 enfants
en situation donc de TSA et
on leur quand ils donc
se rendent à la RS
pour pouvoir créer leur structure pour
pouvoir s'organiser et bien on les
renvoie vers le département du
Pas-de-Calais ou vers la région
en leur disant que finalement pour le
montage de dossiers il existe des
subventions et dans les départements et
dans les régions mais ils ne sont
absolument pas accompagnés et donc moi
j'aimerais que l'on puisse réfléchir au
rôle des des ARS si vous me le permettez
on aurait tellement de choses à dire
mais j'arrête là merci merci voilà
madame la ministre beaucoup de questions
[Musique]
madame la sénatrice concernant l'école
inclusive
pour les pardons pour les pardons pour
les les
personnes sourdes
bon les moyens existent c'est pas une
question de moyens c'est c'est vraiment
une question de professionnelle formée
et nous manquons vraiment de
professionnelle formés c'est une pénurie
générale donc nous travaillons
à
donner un petit peu de visibilité aux
formations nécessaires et puis nous
travaillons aussi dans tous les secteurs
de la Langue des Signes Française qui
est un vrai un vrai enjeu
voilà donc sachez que nous ne sommes pas
voilà nous ne sommes pas insensibles à
ce sujet et le problème c'est un
problème de recrutement de
professionnels mais ce n'est pas une
question de moyens
de moyens pour pour bien sur les
personnes sourdes
ma sénatrice guidez
les parcours les parcours quels sont les
solutions après les cursus maternel pour
les enfants
autistes puisque c'est de ça que nous
que vous parlez je trouve de
neurodéveloppement pardon
les les unités maternelles se déploient
et les unités élémentaires se déploient
également et puis ensuite on a aussi les
classes ULIS qui se déploient avec
et aussi ces fameux dispositifs
d'auto-régulation qui sont vraiment des
choses totalement différentes où en fait
c'est tout l'établissement scolaire
école ou collège qui est complètement
formée à à l'accueil des personnes en
situation de handicap et à la prise en
charge de ces handicaps il n'y a pas de
d'Ash et chaque chaque personne de
enseignante ou personnelles de des
établissements étant capacité de
répondre par des formations spécifiques
et bien sûr ça s'appelle des dispositifs
d'auto-régulation de répondre à la
demande des familles tout cela se
construit progressivement
on ne peut pas enfin bon imaginez le
nombre de formations qu'il faut imaginer
le nombre
d'un message qu'il faut former également
les classes ULIS
représente des très bons moyens pour
continuer la scolarité pour certains
enfants et moi qui me paraît important
c'est pas de faire rentrer dans la case
des dispositifs des personnes c'est de
construire des parcours avec chacun en
fonction de ce besoin est de ces et de
faire en sorte en fonction des besoins
de pouvoir l'insérer dans le bon
dispositif sans rupture
l'idéal sera ça c'est que nous n'ayons
pas de rupture dans dans cette prise en
charge et je crois que c'est une
ambition qui est une ambition importante
la mobilité des transports
bon je crois qu'il nous faut mettre à
plat les différents modes de financement
de transport c'est illisible bon alors
les les autorités organisatrices de
transport scolaire sont les régions
aujourd'hui mais on a laissé au
département les personnes en situation
de handicap sachant que il y a quand
même des familles qui ont et des enfants
dans des
qui n'ont pas de handicap particulier et
des enfants en situation de handicap
donc ils doivent faire appel en fait
tout ça tout ça c'est Kafka donc nous
devons véritablement enfin ça fait
partie d'un des sujets de simplification
que je souhaiterais porter pour que les
familles soient plus voilà arrivent à
faire en sorte de d'y voir plus clair et
nous avons installé un comité
stratégique tel que prévu par la loi qui
pilote tous ces travaux
avec une composition élargie à tous les
niveaux de collectivité territorial donc
ce comité associé aussi les
parlementaires et je crois que il faut
que nous poursuivions ce travail pour
arriver à donner des solutions simples
lisibles et facilement
mobilisable par les familles qui en ont
besoin
la revalorisation des des salaires oui
alors bon
je vais pas le Ségur a quand même été un
effort très très important en faveur des
des professionnels du champ sanitaire et
du d'une partie du champ médico-social
en réponse alors c'était en réponse à la
crise sanitaire mais c'est surtout parce
que ces professions ont besoin d'être
revalorisées et ont besoin
d'une juste d'une juste reconnaissance
et surtout d'attractivité également 12
milliards d'euros qui ont été consacrés
en 2022 à l'ensemble des mesures en
général l'ensemble en février dernier la
conférence des métiers sociaux a permis
de nouvelles avancées avec l'annonce par
le premier ministre Jean Castex d'un
milliard trois d'euros supplémentaires
et qui permet d'étendre et qui
permettait d'étendre ces 183 euros à la
filière socio-éducative et
le premier ministre Jean Castex réservé
500 millions d'euros converger vers une
Convention collective unique
et nous appelons de nos vœux les tous
les gestionnaires en définitive et je
les vois les uns après les autres pour
qu'ils travaillent sur cette convention
collective unique qui permettra de pour
ceux qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas eu
qui ne sont pas rentrés dans le champ de
ces augmentations de pouvoir bien tout
simplement au travers de cette
convention unique de pouvoir avoir une
revalorisation de ces métiers et cette
convention unique elle est très
importante parce que aujourd'hui il y a
des conventions ou par exemple le
démarrage d'une carrière dans certaines
domaines est inférieur au SMIC tout ça
n'est pas possible donc voilà tout ça
n'est pas c'est pas voilà la convention
actuelle est le date de 40 ans enfin moi
ou 30 ans enfin je ne sais plus donc il
faut vraiment et 500 millions d'euros
avaient été fléchés par le Premier
ministre de l'époque pour converger
cette convention collective donc moi
c'est le le pari que nous prenons et le
parti que nous prenons pour pour évoluer
dans ce domaine là
[Musique]
délégation
excusez-moi
délégation des crédits ARS ah oui alors
pour les revalorisations qui elles ont
été décidées mises en œuvre
je ne sais pas c'est vous qui me posez
la question madame la sénatrice l'ARS
est au rendez-vous de cette de à Sissi
la RS a versé les fonds
et donc les associations gestionnaires
pour celles qui
ont une part de leur activité qui est
aussi financée par les départements
attendent de la la part des
départementales pour pouvoir mettre en
œuvre alors certains font lavance
d'autres ne n'osent pas faire l'avance
parce qu'ils ont une trésorerie trop
faible et ça je peux le comprendre mais
la part de l'État a été mobilisée au
niveau des RSA et et voilà
bah écoutez je peux vous assurer que la
part de l'État est mobilisée ça c'est
une certitude enfin elle a été mise en
oeuvre dans toutes les dans toutes les
ARS
donc si vous avez des exemples
chypreuses vous nous faites passer vous
faites passer à mon cabinet tout ça et
on étudiera tout ça avec attention
bon l'autisme et vous êtes plusieurs à
avoir parlé de tout cela et de
l'inclusion en général bon moi vous
savez
je suis quelqu'un de pragmatique
nous sommes quand même nous avons été un
peu mis à l'index de façon sévère par
l'ONU
elle est la France était mise à l'index
et ne respectant pas les préconisations
justement internationales sur la prise
en compte du handicap qui devrait être
dans une inclusion totale dans la
société bon alors bon
je pense que les les principes de l'ONU
sont des bons principes les avis qui ont
été donnés sur notre façon de gérer le
handicap sont sévères et que
mais que bon voilà la vérité aussi elle
doit être pragmatique je suis
[Musique]
bon d'abord c'est l'autodétermination
des personnes en situation de handicap
qui doit être notre boussole ce qu'elle
décide pour la règle et pour leur vie
deuxièmement je suis comme vous les
situations de grands polyhandicap dans
les masses on a du mal à imaginer les
familles ont du mal à imaginer comment
elle ferait sans ces établissements donc
la vérité est au milieu comme d'habitude
et elle est dans le bon sens et dans le
bon sens des situations ce qui est
certain c'est que notre pays
historiquement a une prise en compte du
handicap qui était une prise en compte
très institutionnelle qui a d'abord été
initié par les associations de parents
d'enfants
nés avec des handicaps et ça a été très
institutionnel ce qui m'était en
définitive les personnes en situation de
handicap hors du regard et hors de la
vie sociétale bien souvent et c'est ce
renversement quand on parle religion
c'est vraiment ce renversement que nous
voulons réaliser avec
l'inclusion à l'école
avec différents moyens
médico-sociaux pour aider à cette
inclusion mais avec aussi l'inclusion
à l'inclusion dans le travail j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure et c'est une
des politiques que je souhaite mener
avec ambition
avec voilà l'inclusion dans le sport
l'inclusion dans la culture enfin à tous
les niveaux de notre société alors oui
nous avons besoin de changer de regard
notre société a besoin de continuer à
changer de regard mais en même temps
nous savons tous que nous aurons
toujours besoin d'établissement pour
certains types de handicaps très lourds
donc voilà et vous parliez d'autisme il
y a des autistes très sévères avaient
des jeunes autistes complexes pour
lesquels d'ailleurs dans le PLFSS il y a
des moyens à louer spécifiquement pour
créer des des
structures des habitats regroupés ou des
habitats inclusifs ou des structures
pour les accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions avec des moyens
médico-sociaux adaptés donc voilà un je
suis je crois qu'il faut que nous
restions dans cette ligne continuer
l'inclusion
parce que je reste persuadé que
l'inclusion scolaire est une bonne chose
beaucoup d'enfants progressent beaucoup
d'enfants sont ensuite aptes à rentrer
dans des apprentissages dans des lycées
professionnels et la réforme du lycée
professionnel je vais travailler avec
Carole Grandjean justement pour que ces
enfants soient puissent être accueillis
dans de bonnes conditions et tous les
tous les dispositifs de soutien à
l'emploi doivent être déployés aussi
voilà un vrai parcours de vie
ce qu'il nous faut envisager cette
ambitieux mais je crois que un parcours
de vie adapté à la typologie des
handicaps
les aidants les aidants nous avons eu la
Journée nationale des aidants la semaine
dernière les aidants c'est beaucoup de
monde dans notre pays beaucoup de
personnes qui s'ignorent et donc je
voudrais que nous ayons un vrai une
vraie attention pour les jeunes aidants
parce qu'ils peuvent être en vrai
difficulté ce sont des adolescents ou
des jeunes des jeunes adultes qui sont
en pleine voilà en pleine
ils prennent en main leur vie en
définitive avec déjà des poids sur leurs
épaules nous devons les aider et puis
les aidants âgés aussi qui qui
font qui ne se soignent pas qui sont
isolés qui sont en détresse
psychologique donc oui à des lieux de
répit qui vont se multiplier et nous
avons
nous avons
des enveloppes qui sont et des appels à
projets pour des lieux de répit qui ont
été
alors oui le covid a ralenti ces projets
mais il y a 252 plateformes qui ont été
déployés bien sûr et nous allons
poursuivre et ça fera partie je crois
aussi la prise en compte des aidants de
de la Conférence nationale du handicap
il me faut vraiment soutenir les aidants
sachant que c'est aussi Jean-Christophe
combe qui travaille sur ces sujets et
c'est aussi le ministre de la Santé qui
travaille sur ces sujets des aidants qui
qui sont une part très très importante
de notre société
l'emploi accompagné l'emploi accompagné
oui il y a des budgets et oui ça fait
partie de mes budgets j'en suis assez
fier d'ailleurs mais sur le PLF
et nous avons reconduit l'enveloppe de
cette de ce dispositif d'emploi
accompagné qui est un dispositif très
pertinent et que j'ai bien l'intention
de faire prospérer voire même amplifier
tant les résultats sont encourageants et
intéressants pour le soutien à la mise
en emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap et France travail
France travaille se construit
actuellement France travaille se
construit avec tous les acteurs et bien
entendu sont autour de la table pour la
partie handicap Cap emploi avec Pôle
Emploi Cap Emploi bien sûr là j'ai
Philippe la fille pH donc tous les
acteurs de
de l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap et mon cabinet aussi
participe aux réunions de la mise en
oeuvre de de France travail donc le
handicap sera pleinement pris en compte
et l'accès à l'emploi et au maintien de
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap seront une politique pour moi
prioritaire
enfin
madame la sénatrice
meunier je crois
il est parti bon donc elle doutait elle
doutait de nos ambitions et
elle est partie elle est dotée de nos
ambitions elle va continuer d'en douter
donc c'est l'écoute pas ma réponse dont
nos ambitions elles sont vraiment
importantes nous avons
nous avons
sa se traduit ça s'est traduit au niveau
des budgets ça se traduit aussi on peut
pas dire qu'on n'est pas ambitieux comme
par exemple on a un plan une stratégie
autisme avait 500 millions d'euros à sur
la table bon voilà donc nous allons
poursuivre et nous avons encore beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir ensemble changer
le regard oui je suis d'accord c'est
notre société entière qui doit changer
le regard parce que l'inclusion ne se
fera aussi qu'avec un changement de
regard de la société ce qui va nous
permettre de changer ce regard aussi et
j'attends ce moment avec impatience ce
sont les Jeux paralympiques de 2024 qui
vont donner véritablement un éclairage
sur le handicap de très très positif
donc servons-nous de ce levier au
travers de ces champions pour aussi
communiquer au travers communiqué de
façon très positive sur ce qu'apporte
aussi les personnes handicapées à notre
société comme toute comme personne le
besoin d'établissement bon j'ai répondu
un petit peu
les
les places en masse et en femmes sur le
budget sur le Pell FSS c'est ça de là de
2023 il y a plus de 1000 places qui sont
inscrites qui correspond à 55 millions
d'euros
oui oui donc ben voilà nous tout ça ce
sont des appels approfins des appels à
projets qui sont ensuite
mis en mis en application par des
acteurs qui soient qu'ils soient que ce
soit des collectivités que ce soit des
des absolument il y a des moyens
et enfin la simplification
la simplification oui tout est complexe
oui les familles d'un nom plus cassé de
remplir 20 fois le même dossier nos
comprennent pas d'ailleurs cette
situation parce que c'est assez
incompréhensible donc je veux vraiment
que nous allions vers la simplification
des procédures mais c'est un travail que
nous devons mener avec les maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées qui sont le véritable c'est
le véritable verrou de l'accès
personne handicapée et ce travail a
commencé à être
déployé avec le soutien de la CNSA qui
engagé un travail important parce que ça
passera par le l'outil numérique qui
engagé un travail important avec toutes
les MDPH pour travailler sur l'outil
numérique harmonisé déjà et pouvoir
faire en sorte de voilà enfin le
dites-le dites le nous une fois doit
s'appliquer aussi aux personnes en
situation de handicap pour tout ce qui
est bien sûr handicap qui ne bouge pas
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui ne
bougent pas quand il y a bien longtemps
dû des des éléments nouveaux sans
reprendre l'intégralité du dossier ne
reprendre que la partie élément nouveau
et qui puisse décider donc oui nous
avons besoin de simplification il y a
une deuxième chose dont je voudrais
parler qui qui alors simplification
réponse plus rapide un gros travail a
été fait également avec les MDPH nous
arrivons maintenant à une nette
amélioration des délais de réponse et
j'en suis très heureuse et il faut
poursuivre et troisième
troisième élément moi qui
me perturbe un petit peu c'est
l'hétérogénéité des réponses données en
fonction des MDPH et des départements
donc
ce qui est met les familles dans
l'incompréhension c'est à dire qu'elles
ont un certain type de soutien dans un
département elle déménage pour des
raisons professionnelles dans un autre
département d'abord elle recommence tout
le dossier à zéro et ensuite elles n'ont
pas les mêmes prises en charge qui leur
sont proposées
enfin moi je les écoute je n'ai pas de
de pratique personnelle des MDPH mais
j'écoute les associations c'est quand
même ce qui revient souvent et notamment
des parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap donc il faut travailler à une
homogénéisation des pratiques de des
MDPH mais tout ça n'est pas hors de
portée bien sûr et ce n'est que du bon
sens en définitive
voilà merci madame la ministre et à
bientôt belfs merci beaucoup de votre
accueil et je vous remercie de votre
intérêt pour tous ces sujets qui sont
essentiels merci merci